unfortunately for everyone we seem to go
around the world with scripts in our
minds a script is a collection of
expectations about how events will
unfold and how we should best respond to
them built up out of the worst moments
of our childhoods and our most immature
and frightened deductions they're from
here are some representative Scripts
when I make a mistake I will get shouted
at uncontrollably therefore I must never
admit I'm at fault or will I trust
someone they betray me therefore I must
never open up or if I get too emotional
there will be chaos therefore I must be
very Stern and detached or if a partner
is out of contact for a while this means
they've abandoned me therefore I need to
flare up at any threat of absence
these scripts tell us a lot about our
pasts but the tragedy is that unaware
they exist we let them determine our
futures we insistently layer them onto
situations in the here and now that
could have had far more benevolent
endings
a boss very gently points out a mistake
and out of a fear that this is a Prelude
to Relentless humiliation we snap back
or our partner lets us down in a minor
way
sure that this means they're about to
destroy us we start to insult them
the solution is to recognize that there
can be different endings yes I made a
mistake but the result doesn't have to
be cruel reprimand yes the partner let
me down but they can and do still love
me very much I could get annoyed but the
emotion doesn't have to escalate
uncontrollably
in other words what happened originally
doesn't have to keep happening but only
if we can first understand what actually
happened
and to help us with this we should
explore the past by completing the
following sentences
when I make a mistake
when I trust someone
if I get too emotional
if a partner has to be out of touch for
a while
the end goal of maturity might be
defined as the ability to approach as
much of life as possible without a
script